et notre invité politique ce matin c'est
Olivier du socle bonjour merci beaucoup
d'être avec nous du travail de
l'insertion et du plein emploi c'est
vous évidemment qui portait la réforme
des retraites on va longuement parler
pendant 20 minutes pour une interview
avec la presse régionale représentée par
Christelle Bertrand du groupe La Dépêche
bonjour Christelle bonjour Oriane
bonjour Olivier dupe c'est jour de CMP
de commission mixte paritaire vous
pensez qu'elle sera conclusive j'espère
les députés les sénateurs de la CMP vont
se réunir ce matin et j'espère qu'ils
vont pouvoir trouver un texte d'accord
et un texte de compromis entre les
travaux que l'assemblée a mené en
commission qu'elle a essayé de mener
malgré une struction systématique des
groupes de gauche sur l'assemblée et
puis le taxe du Sénat taxe du Sénat qui
a été débattu jusqu'au bout qui a été
voté intégralement avec des dispositions
qui sont fortes et qui ont été votées
par le Sénat avec une large majorité le
relèvement de l'âge mais aussi la
fermeture des régimes spéciaux ou encore
des dispositions qui permettent de mieux
valoriser les trimestres obtenus au
titre de la maternité et de la
parentalité à la fin d'une carrière vous
êtes inquiet si la CMP n'était pas
conclusive ce serait grave ne place pas
dans cette logique là si la CMP n'était
pas conclusive la procédure est prévue
il y aurait de nouvelles lectures et un
débat parlementaire qui continuerait
mais je suis vraiment convaincu que
cette CMP sans empris jugé c'est le rôle
des parlementaires que de la mener et de
l'organiser mais je suis convaincu que
cette CMP peut aboutir notamment parce
que il y a des points communs entre ce
que défend la majorité présidentielle à
l'Assemblée est-ce que la majorité
sénatoriale a voulu au Sénat il n'y a
pas que des points communs il y a aussi
des écarts des différences c'est le
débat démocratique c'est très normal
mais il y a des points communs il y a un
point commun majeur sur le fait que
cette réforme va permettre l'équilibre
financier du système en 2030 parce que
c'est la condition pour que ce système
puisse être pérennisé pour qu'il puisse
durer pour que la retraite par
répartition la solidarité
intergénérationnelle puisse être
préservée donc ça c'est un socle
d'accord qui était extrêmement fort et
puis il y a des points communs aussi sur
la question de l'emploi des seniors avec
le même objectif de l'améliorer sur la
question de de la pénibilité de sa
prévention sur des questions carrière
longue qui font l'objet de débat et des
débats qui traversent d'ailleurs toutes
les familles politiques alors vous
parlez par exemple de l'emploi des
seniors est-ce qu'il y a des points qui
peuvent encore être améliorés par la CMP
aujourd'hui je crois que le Sénat a fait
deux choix de choix principaux en tout
cas en matière d'emploi des seniors
premier choix c'est de voter l'index il
n'avait pas été voté à l'Assemblée
nationale il a été voté au Sénat avec
cette volonté d'avoir un outil de mesure
qui permette de mieux prendre en compte
de mieux tenir compte de l'implication
des entreprises en matière d'emploi des
seniors je pense que nous pouvons que la
CMP pardon peut peut l'améliorer
notamment pour faire en sorte que le
coercitif par exemple coercitif je suis
pas sûr que ce soit le bon mot mais mais
faire en sorte que lorsque une
entreprise a rempli l'index et que elle
a respecté les différentes obligations
mais que sa situation en matière
d'emploi des seigneurs se dégradent que
les efforts ne sont pas au rendez-vous
en tout cas que les actions ne sont pas
au rendez-vous qu'il y ait une nécessité
une obligation d'une certaine manière
pour l'entreprise de mettre en place des
plans d'action en gardant le seuil de
300 salariés ça ça fait partie des
divergences c'est ce que le Sénat a voté
le seuil à 300 était le seuil que le
gouvernement a proposé dans le projet de
loi tel qu'il a été présenté à
l'assemblée ensuite l'Assemblée a voté
un amendement abaissant le seuil à 50
mais l'assemblé a aussi voté la
suppression de l'article portant index
donc à la sortie de l'assemblée il n'y
avait plus grand chose concernant
l'index dans le texte ça fait partie des
discussions 300 ça reste le bon soy pour
vous ça fait partie des discussions CMP
ça change elle se réunit ce matin ce
n'est pas le gouvernement
n'y siège pas nous ce qu'on souhaite
c'est un outil qui soit le plus efficace
possible de même que nous souhaitons
continuer à échanger et c'est le travail
de cette commission autour d'autres
initiatives du Sénat comme le CDI senior
qui a été adopté par le Sénat donc
considérons que le champ est extrêmement
large avec des risques d'effet
d'aubaines mais des discussions peuvent
avoir lieu pour voir comment mieux le
circonscrire l'encadrer et vous
souhaitez qu'il soit maintenu mais un
peu différemment si c'est le point si
c'est le point d'atterrissage si je peux
dire les choses de la commission mixte
paritaire pourquoi pas certains députés
évoquent notamment la baisse des charges
pour des entreprises qui garderaient
leur Seigneur dans leurs effectifs ça
pourrait être quelque chose nous avons
fait beaucoup en termes d'allongement du
coût du travail et ne sont pas de baisse
de cotisation je préfère ce mot-là
homocharge de manière générale on doit
avoir en tête qu'aujourd'hui avec les
allégements généraux il y a les genoux
Fillon avec le cice créé par François
Hollande et que nous avons transformé en
allègement pérenne jusqu'à 1,6 Smic les
cotisations les exonérations de
cotisations sont déjà très fortes et
au-delà de 1 sismique nous avons ce
qu'on appelle les exonérations anti du
bandeau famille qui mettent en place un
système d'exonération qui est aussi
important
aller plus loin en matière d'exonération
c'est vraiment consacrer les
exonérations sur les salaires les plus
élevés et je ne suis pas sûr que ce soit
le plus efficace de la majorité n'iront
pas dans ce sens là aujourd'hui je vous
l'ai dit c'est un exercice particulier
la CMP serait né dans quelques dizaines
de minutes et c'est vraiment un Dieu ou
le Sénat et l'Assemblée sans la présence
du gouvernement mais le Sénat et
l'Assemblée leur délégation respective
doivent travailler se mettre d'accord on
évoque aussi des efforts des
aménagements sur la retraite des femmes
et les inégalités femmes hommes c'est
quelque chose que vous avez en tête nous
avons nous avons deux chantiers en la
matière nous avons un premier chantier
qui concerne des mesures que nous avons
intégrées dans le texte dès le départ
tenir compte par exemple de trimestres
cotiser au titre de l'assurance
vieillesse pour les parents foyers ça
concerne beaucoup de trimestres de congé
parentaux créer une assurance vieillesse
pour les aidants familiaux on sait que
cela concerne essentiellement des femmes
et intégrer ces trimestres obtenus au
titre d'un rôle des dons ou au titre du
congé parental dans les trimestres
retenus pour permettre un départ
anticipé pour carrière longue pour
permettre un accès à la pension minimum
c'est ce que nous avons proposé nous
avons proposé et accepté d'autres choses
dans le texte il y a une mesure qui a
été votée au Sénat avec le soutien du
gouvernement qui consiste à dire que
lorsqu'un assuré principalement des
femmes mais n'assurer qu'il bénéficient
qu'il y a sont dans sa carrière des
trimestres de maternité des trimestres
éducation et qui du coup a atteint la
durée de d'affiliation au régime la
fameuse on dit durée de cotisation c'est
une durée d'affiliation au régime à 63
ans puisse pour les 4 trimestres entre
63 64 ans bénéficier d'une surcote et
une surcote sur 4 trimestres c'est 5% de
revalorisation de la pension c'est une
initiative du président Retailleau nous
l'avons soutenu ça reste et je souhaite
que ça puisse rester dans le texte puis
il y a un deuxième chantier sur cette
question des femmes et des droits
familiaux au sens le plus large du terme
qui est un chantier dans un deuxième
temps ou au-delà du texte retraite c'est
d'abord un chantier sur l'action de
l'égalité aujourd'hui lorsque une femme
a un enfant ou lorsque vous adoptez vous
bénéficiez de quatre trimestres
d'accueil de l'enfant si vous êtes
affilié au régime général si vous êtes
affilié au régime de la fonction
publique c'est deux trimestres donc on a
un chantier d'harmonisation on a aussi
le même chantier d'harmonisation sur les
pensions de réversion et avec la
première ministre nous avons dit dès le
10 janvier que nous souhaitons que
courant 2023 ce chantier puisse être
ouvert et puis dernier point quand on
parle d'égalité entre les femmes et les
hommes à la retraite on sait que les
pensions sont très différentes entre les
hommes et les femmes ce n'est pas le
système de retraite qui crée l'inégalité
de pension le système de retraite il n'a
pas des règles et il n'a pas de règle
défavorable aux femmes ou favorable aux
hommes le système de retraite il renvoie
soit sur l'existant il rend les
inégalités qu'il a enregistré et donc la
seule façon et la vraie façon de
garantir une égalité de retraite entre
les femmes et les hommes c'est de
garantir l'égalité professionnelle et
l'égalité de carrière c'est un chantier
énorme qui progresse on peut considérer
qu'il ne progresse pas assez vite c'est
le cas donc il faut à chaque fois qu'on
ne peut pousser les feux et être plus
offensif sur l'égalité professionnelle
parce que c'est quand on aura réalisé
l'égalité professionnelle entre les
femmes et les hommes qu'on aura
l'égalité de retraite un mot sur les
carrières longues puisque ça fait partie
des divergences entre les proresformes
un cristal oui sur l'amendement Pradier
qui est un sujet de discussion depuis
les
de la spiruline nationale est-ce que
vous allez l'élargir à d'autres tranches
d'âge est-ce que c'est en dessous du
gouvernement la première ministre lors
de la dernière semaine de débat
l'Assemblée nationale indiqué qu'elle
voulait qu'on complète le dispositif de
carrière longue dispositif qui prévoit
de des départs anticipés pour les
personnes qui ont commencé à travailler
avant 16 ans pour les personnes qui ont
commencé à travailler avant 20 ans ça
c'est la loi actuelle et nous souhaitons
nous souhaitions dès le début du débat
créer un troisième niveau pour ceux qui
ont commencé avant 18 ans qu'ils un
départ encore plus anticipés que ceux
qui ont commencé entre 18 et 20 ans
parce que ça nous paraît juste avec le
relèvement de l'âge un débat est né
autour de ceux qui commencent le jour de
leurs 20 ans pour simplifier un peu les
choses caricaturer un peu et qui du coup
devrait travailler mécaniquement plus
longtemps pour atteindre les 64 ans la
première ministre a dit qu'elle
souhaitait créer une quatrième borne
d'âge pour ceux qui commencent à vendre
21 ans donc ça c'est acté et le Sénat
l'avoter nous souhaitons que ça reste il
y a un débat autour des ajustements des
encadrements de la durée de cotisation
requise pour bénéficier du départ
carrière longue pour ceux qui commencent
à 20 ans c'est le débat qui nous a
occupé le vendredi
majeurs pardon un des points majeurs de
discussion de la commission mixte
paritaire ça pourrait évoluer ou est-ce
que vous avez demandé à la majorité
puisque la première ministre a reçu les
membres de la majorité qui s'agit en CMP
de ne pas céder sur ce point où est-ce
qu'il est possible qu'à l'issue de la
CMP il soit acté que aucun Français en
carrière longue ne travaillera
on va laisser la CMP travailler
quelle est la volonté de la majorité
présidentielle la volonté de la majorité
présidentielle la volonté du
gouvernement celle de la première de la
première ministre et la mienne c'est que
la CMP puisse s'aboutir donc et aboutir
je précise aboutir en gardant à la fois
cette volonté d'améliorer le système de
le rendre toujours plus juste mais avec
un autre objectif qui est l'équilibre
financier en 2030 et donc la CMP a ce
point ça fait partie des points de
discussion il en a quelques-uns et c'est
normal puisque nous ne pouvons pas
imaginez ne vont pas demander que les
textes votés soient parfaitement
identiques avant d'entrer en commission
mixte paritaire et il y a aussi un
principe qui fait que la commission
mixte paritaire se tient entre député et
sénateurs sans gouvernement donc
respectons les rythmes faisons les
choses les unes après les autres mais
nous verrons ce qui vous seriez
favorable si la CMP de la CMP il sort
que plus aucun Français en carrière
longue ne travaille plus de 43 ans vous
dites d'accord à condition que ce soit
compensée par ailleurs je ne préjugue
pas de ce que dira la CMP je ne fais pas
les conclusions de la CMP à la place des
députés et des sénateurs
de la majorité vous savez j'ai pas de
consigne il y a une réunion à matinée
pas de consignes qu'il y a un accord
entre les gouvernement de la majorité
les députés la majorité ne reçoivent pas
de consignes députés de la majorité font
de la politique ils ont des idées des
convictions et nous les partageons donc
nous travaillons ensemble c'est pas tout
à fait la même chose que parler de
consignes
par exemple de l'équilibre du texte ce
ne sont pas les seuls je crois que la
majorité sénatoriale est aussi très
attentive parce que l'équipe financiers
la majorité
il y a 10 jours vous disiez qu'il
manquerait 300 à 400 millions en 2030
avec l'état du texte depuis le texte a
été voté par le Sénat avec des
modifications aujourd'hui on en est où
du chiffre que j'indiqué intégré les
modifications proposées par la
commission des affaires sociales du
Sénat donc on est donc là le texte va
sortir la CMP j'en suis sûr avec un
équilibre financier c'est voulu par tout
le monde qu'est-ce que ça implique ça
implique de regarder les mesures qui ont
été votées qui génèrent des recettes
c'est le cas de la lutte contre la
fraude c'est le cas de l'harmonisation
du régime fiscal et social en matière de
rupture conventionnelle qui a été votée
à l'Assemblée nationale c'est aussi
prioriser faire des choix parmi les
différentes mesures c'est à nouveau le
rôle de la Commission Mixte Paritaire
mais c'est extrêmement important que le
texte si la commission mixte paritaire
est conclusive que le texte qui en sort
et dont j'espère qu'il sera adopté
ensuite par le Sénat puis l'Assemblée
nationale soit un texte équilibré nous
tenons cette ligne depuis le début j'ai
toujours dit qu'il nous avions deux
objectifs et équilibré améliorer si on
se contente d'équilibrer c'est très
budgétaire et ça n'est pas forcément
très juste si on se contente d'améliorer
de créer des droits et donc des dépenses
ça n'est pas très responsable donc il
faut faire les deux mais là on en est
toujours à il manque 300 400 millions
d'ici 2030 c'était la prévision au
moment du débat c'était important de
dire au fur et à mesure des débats
quelles conséquences ça avait mais je
sais j'ai une grande confiance dans les
députés et les sénateurs qui souhaitent
l'aboutissement de la commission mixte
paritaire sur leur capacité à faire en
sorte que cet aboutissement se traduise
aussi par un équilibre financier je vais
vous demander qu'est-ce qui se passe si
puisque le gouvernement vous l'avez
précisé à plusieurs reprises n'est pas
ne fait pas partie de cette CMP il peut
y avoir de grosses surprises qu'est-ce
que vous faites si elle sortir le texte
n'est pas équilibré
et je l'ai dit la majorité
présidentielle à l'Assemblée et son
représentants ces représentants ancienna
et la majorité sénatoriale disent de
manière régulière répétée constante que
n'importe que l'équilibre financier du
système est important
Mathilde panot la présidente du groupe
insoumis à l'Assemblée nationale elle
veut faire vivre la Commission mixparita
en direct sur les réseaux sociaux face
au refus de yalbrun Pivet de la rendre
publique vous comprenez ça non non des
institutions il y a des règles et la
commission n'existe paritaire a toujours
fait l'objet d'un compte rendu mais
c'est un lieu de discussion c'est une
réunion avant toute travail je suis
député depuis 2016
à la fois comme membre en tant que
député comme rapporteur de projet de loi
sont des réunions de travail d'échanges
souvent très techniques d'ailleurs mais
derrière la technique il y a des aspects
politiques et ça nécessite aussi une
forme de comment dire il faut une
organisation de la Réunion qui permet
des échanges très spontanés très direct
pour trouver des points d'atterrissage
pour trouver des points d'équilibre et
pour trouver des points d'entente il y a
toujours eu des comptes rendus parce que
le compte rendu de la commission mixte
paritaire doit être connu à la fois pour
le Conseil constitutionnel qui vérifie
les conditions dans lesquelles la loi a
été votée et puis c'est important de
savoir comment les groupes politiques
les parlementaires ont pu se positionner
mais il y a des règles et un des
problèmes en tout cas une des tendances
assez régulière des membres de la France
insoumise c'est de vouloir casser les
règles et de vouloir remettre en cause
le fonctionnement des institutions
peut-être peut-être je n'utilise pas
forcément la même expression mais l'idée
là ce huis clos donne pas le sentiment
qu'il y a des choses à cacher qui a des
deals qui seraient passées au sein de la
mutemp on entend bien non au cours de la
tour était ainsi et c'est bien ainsi
parce que lorsque vous cherchez un point
d'atterrissage à un point de compromis
il faut des deal il faut non il faut on
peut appeler ça des deal mais il faut
des discussions et et vous entrez dans
un lorsque les choses ne sont pas faites
vous entrez dans une commission mixte
paritaire lorsque vous êtes par exemple
rapporteur je l'étais à plusieurs
reprises avec des positions qui peuvent
être des positions de discussions et le
problème d'une position de discussion
c'est que pardon je vais être un peu
familier mais parfois vous demandez 100
pour avoir 50 parce que c'est une disc
et si votre interlocuteur dit zéro vous
dites 100 l'objectif c'est peut-être de
finir à 50 à 60 ou à 40 et évidemment
c'est une discussion parce que nous
devons les membres de la CMP doivent
concilier des positions qui sont
différentes pour trouver un compromis et
donc qu'il y a un compte rendu qu'il y
ait des traces de ce qui s'est passé en
CMP c'est normal mais c'est aussi normal
que les sept députés les sénateurs
puissent avoir ce lieu où ils se
retrouvent pour de la conciliation quand
vous êtes dans des procédures
contradictoires quand vous êtes en
conflit y compris dans notre vie
personnelle dans notre vie
professionnelle et qui a des moments de
conciliation avec des médiateurs avec
des moments où on essaye de trouver un
point d'attente avant d'aller vers un
conflit ou vers une opposition ouvert
une procédure généralement le plus
efficace c'est quand même quand vous
pouvez discuter dans un cadre de
confiance
de main le texte reviendra au Parlement
au Sénat le matin à l'Assemblée
nationale l'après-midi si tout ça est
conclusif la majorité est à 287
puisqu'il y a des sièges non pourvu à
l'Assemblée nationale à combien ce matin
estimez-vous le nombre de députés
des comptages et des croix et des cochez
des cases on imagine que vous mettez
quand même je pense que je pense que si
tous les députés qui sont attachés à la
pérennité à la survie du système par
répartition si tous les députés qui sont
attachés à la solidarité
intergénérationnelle si tous les députés
qui considèrent que la bonne clé et la
bonne solution c'est de travailler un
peu plus de manière progressive de
manière adaptée et surtout de ne pas
augmenter les impôts de ne pas baisser
le pouvoir d'achat et de ne pas baisser
les pensions si tous les députés qui
sont attachés à une meilleure prise en
compte de la pénibilité et des carrières
longues vote et vote pour un texte dans
lequel il se retrouve il n'y a pas de
problème de majorité mais il faut qu'il
soit là il faut que leur vote soit aussi
acquis autour d'un texte qui répond à
leurs demandes le texte tel qu'il est
sorti du Sénat et je j'espère on va voir
ce que donne la commission mixte mais
tel qu'il pourrait sortir de la
commission mixte paritaire est un texte
qui répond aux attentes de la majorité
présidentielle bien sûr c'est un
engagement du Président de la République
un engagement pris par tous les députés
lors de leur propre campagne aux
élections législatives c'est aussi un
texte qui répond aux attentes de
beaucoup de groupes d'oppositions et
notamment du groupe des Républicains le
groupe des Républicains voulaient que
l'on aide mieux les parents et notamment
les mères de famille c'est le cas il
voulait une meilleure prise en compte
des carrières longues c'est le cas il
voulait que la revalorisation des
petites tensions s'applique au retraites
actuel et pas seulement aux nouveaux
c'est le cas ils veulent ils voulaient
ils veulent qu'on fasse plus pour les
seniors et l'emploi des seniors je pense
que c'est le cas que ça sera le cas donc
et pourtant leur vote n'est pas en tout
cas le vote de d'une partie du groupe
qu'est-ce que vous leur dites d'une
partie du groupe à l'Assemblée nationale
et en fait il ne faut pas que les
considérations de politique partisanes
prennent le pas sur la capacité à
défendre une réforme qu'ils ont pour la
plupart d'entre eux pour ne pas dire
tous défendus à l'occasion des dernières
campagnes et qui répond aux attentes
j'avais vu le
la position arrêtée par le Bureau
National des républicains il y a
quelques semaines et avec un bureau
national des républicains qui disait si
ces conditions sont remplies on peut
soutenir la réforme les conditions sont
remplies d'arrêter de faire de la petite
partisane sont remplies donc vous pouvez
soutenir ce texte hier dans les rangs de
la majorité on parlait d'une dizaine de
voix d'avance pour voter ce texte est-ce
que ça correspond à l'impression que
vous avez tout à l'heure que je ne fais
pas des croix des cases
ma priorité est le magasin
depuis le début et jusqu'à jusqu'au
dernier discussion c'est à la fois de
mener cette concertation nous l'avons
mené avec la première ministre nous
avons ouvert conclu et dans notre dans
l'entre-deux nous avons mené avec mon
équipe des dizaines d'heures et les
mêmes des centaines d'heures de
concertation c'est d'améliorer le texte
par la concertation et cette faire en
sorte que le débat parlementaire puisse
s'enrichir le texte ça a été le cas au
Sénat je reviens sur ce sujet là parce
que pour moi c'est un événement un pas
un événement c'est un élément majeur le
débat au Sénat a certes été ralenti par
une volonté d'obstruction de la gauche
avec presque 9000 amendements et sous
amendement mais il est allé au bout il a
été riche je considère qu'il est
entièrement signal et le texte a été
intégralement débattu et voté et c'est
ça mon rôle et je considère que
avec beaucoup accéléré mais comment en
2010 sur la réforme Fillon comme en 2013
sur la réforme Touraine comme en 2014
sur la loi de sécurisation de l'emploi
ça n'est pas une nouveauté par contre
donc ça veut dire que vous allez pouvoir
vous passer du 49-3 depuis le début mais
je ne vous parle pas du début de la
semaine depuis le début de la Réforme
depuis le mois d'octobre le mois de
novembre au mois de décembre le mois de
janvier nous disons que notre objectif
est d'avoir une majorité sur ce texte et
d'avoir une majorité qui nous permette
est-ce que vous dites il y aura pas de
49,3 quoi qu'il arrive vous irez au vote
est-ce que quoi qu'il arrive vous y
revotte et tant pis si le vote ne passe
pas nous souhaitons pouvoir aller au
vote avec une majorité qui à nos yeux
existent sur un texte comme celui-ci
mais il va falloir faire un choix avant
le vote
c'est ce que vous prendrez le risque du
vote pour vous d'abord risque pour vous
parce que vous prendrez le risque
d'abord une décision qui m'appartient et
qui n'appartient pas qu'à moi en tout
cas si décision il y a nécessairement
collective et sous l'autorité de la
première ministre et du président de la
République nous sommes convaincus nous
savons que si tous les députés tous les
sénateurs qui considèrent que cette
réforme est importante et qui ont
exprimé un certain nombre d'attention à
certains de demandes constatent ce qui
est le cas que leur demande sont
mais est-ce que vous jouerez la prudence
si vous avez un doute si demain
après-midi dans l'hémicycle vous avez un
doute est-ce que vous aurez la prudence
et vous sortirez le 49 3 ou est-ce que
vous dites on va au vote et si le vote
nous faisons tout pour avoir une
majorité parce que nous considérons que
cette majorité existe et nous voulons
qu'elle se formalise dans l'hémicycle
vous voulez une majorité parce que vous
craignez aussi peut-être une motion de
censure transpartisane je crois que si
j'ai bien lu les échos de presse et
différents
tuyaux autre expression je crois que
l'opposition
on prépare des émotions de censure à peu
près dans tous les cas de figure jusqu'à
présent ils ont toujours été rejetés
parce qu'il n'y a pas de majorité
alternative il n'y a aucune majorité
alternative à l'Assemblée nationale il
n'y a rien qui puisse permettre à une
majorité de se constituer pour remplacer
celles que nous avons mais vous
conseille des ministres est-ce que il y
a un conseil des ministres qui a déjà
autorisé le 49-3 le dernier conseil des
ministres était la semaine dernière et
ce n'était pas l'heure du jour et c'est
à l'heure du jour de ce matin ça n'est
pas l'heure du jour vous connaissez
l'ordre du jour il est public dans les
options de des oppositions il y a aussi
la possibilité d'une motion de rejet qui
pourrait être disposée par le groupe
lyode est-ce que vous la craignez je
pense que s'il y a une majorité pour le
texte il y a une majorité contre une
motion de rejet vous voyez c'est assez
mécanique
pour le texte et la majorité pour
acheter une motion projet Philippe
Martinez puisque c'est aussi une journée
de mobilisation aujourd'hui un Philippe
Martinez a dit hier soir que le refus
d'Emmanuel Macron de recevoir les
syndicats avait accentué la colère
qu'est-ce que vous lui dites
d'abord je ne crois pas je ne partage
pas mais ça c'est une appréciation j'ai
aussi en tête qu'il y a plusieurs
reprises notamment la mise en place du
Conseil national de la refondation le
même responsable syndical Philippe
Martinez a refusé les invitations des
présidents de la République donc tout ça
n'est pas à géométrie variable la porte
de l'exécutif la porte du gouvernement
m'apporte comme l'a dit la première
ministre et comme l'a dit le président
de la République ce sont des portes qui
sont toujours ouvertes aux partenaires
sociaux pour discuter pour échanger
Emmanuel Macron
parce que le Président de la République
considère il l'a dit qu'il y a un temps
de concertation avec les partenaires
sociaux qui a eu lieu qui a été long qui
a été fructueux n'a pas permis de
surmonter tous les désaccords notamment
sur l'âge mais il a été fructueux sur
beaucoup de points nous avons pu prendre
reprendre à notre compte les
propositions des partenaires sociaux
qu'ils soient des que ce soit
désorganisations syndicales ou des
organisations patronales puis il y a un
temps parlementaire nous sommes dans le
temps parlementaire et le président a
dit que ça n'empêchait pas des
discussions avec le gouvernement mais
qu'il souhaitait que chacun puisse
rester dans son
cas j'aurais dans les prochaines
semaines et les prochains mois à
défendre un projet de Loi sur l'emploi
du travail et de la formation avec c'est
avant l'été les discussions des
discussions vont commencer très vite
parce que notre objectif
c'est juste après la réforme nous avons
dans ce texte dans ce dans ce projet de
loi que je prépare actuellement nous
avons à la fois la volonté d'avoir des
dispositions qui donnent suite aux
acides du travail que j'ai ouvert tant
descendre les conditions
le rapport et les propositions n'ont pas
été faites donc comment est-ce que vous
pouvez dire ça n'est pas productif alors
que le rapport le rapport n'a pas été
rendu et je connais le pré rapport je
sais les pistes de proposition des trois
groupes de travail il y a énormément de
choses que nous pourrons reprendre dans
le projet de Loi sur l'emploi le travail
et la formation nous allons mettre à
profit ce texte de loi pour faire en
sorte que l'accord interprofessionnel
passé entre une majorité de syndicats et
les organisations patronales sur le
partage de la valeur soit inscrit dans
la loi comme dans nous étions engagés
nous allons mettre des dispositions sur
les conditions et la qualité de vie au
travail sur la lutte contre les
accidents graves et mortels nous allons
profiter de ce texte pour améliorer les
dispositions sur la formation continue
les capacités
le dialogue normalement avec la CFDT
évidemment que la réforme des retraites
restera dans les têtes ça ne s'efface
pas ça me saoule pas les relations
exécutives
comme tout événement positif ou négatif
mais ce texte va permettre de noter des
débouchés à la fois des travaux auxquels
les organisations syndicales et
patronales ont participé je pense aux
assises du travail mais aussi des
travaux qu'ils ont mené eux-mêmes comme
sur le partage de la valeur merci
beaucoup Olivier dusoft on espère qu'on
reviendrez nous voir vite parce que le
28 mars arrive au Sénat de la loi
immigration que vous portez avec Gérald
Darmanin et j'espère que vous viendrez
nous en parler merci beaucoup merci
Olivier